liban reprise des combats à beyrouth les
tractations continuent sur les modalités
d'une éventuelle évacuation des
palestiniens scandale au vatican
ouverture d'une information judiciaire
contre le grand argentier monseigneur
martin plüss le rituel de l'été
chassé-croisé sur les routes et
sécheresse accrue dans plusieurs
départements
madame monsieur bonsoir les
préoccupations de millions de français
ce soir se résume en un mot les bouchons
le grand chassé croisé de l'été entre
ceux qui partent et ceux qui rentrent de
vacances a commencé les gars sont
engorgés les orages qui sévissent un peu
partout dans le pays n'arrange rien sur
les routes mais le volume de circulation
est sensiblement le même que l'année
dernière et jusqu'ici la situation n'est
pas trop mauvaise le point ce soir et
quelques conseils si vous devez partir
demain
corinne pertuis en effet toute la
journée chassé-croisé ininterrompue
entre visage pâle et visage bronzé avec
en définitive moins de difficultés que
prévu
moins de difficultés en tout cas que
l'un dernière le même jour aux mêmes
heures
comme à l'habitude points névralgiques
la région de lyon est qu tunnel de
fourvière et le tronçon mâcon tournus
on compte encore cinq kilomètres allant
doucement à lyon autre difficulté sur
l'autoroute du sud à valence avignon
chalon et ball dans le sens entre la
pallice in vers 13 km de bouchons et à
millau saint pourçain sur sioule dans le
sud-ouest difficulté à salbris et la
ferté-saint-aubin le mauvais temps
généralisé a rendu les conditions de
route difficile résultat de nombreux
accidents dont deux carambolages entre
beaune et chalon
si la journée d'aujourd'hui s'est passé
relativement bien demain sera difficile
et dimanche 9 à verra guère
d'amélioration heures défavorable samedi
2-0 heures à midi partez de préférence
l'après midi dimanche à éviter entre 3
heures et 9 heures du matin
une bonne surprise demain pour les
usagers de l'autoroute a9 les
viticulteurs de l'hérault qui ont décidé
de limiter leur manifestation à la
journée de samedi ont distribué des
tracts pour expliquer leur
mécontentement et assurons aussi le
passage gratuit au péage c'est une
affaire sans précédent dans l'histoire
du vatican c'est aussi le premier
incident diplomatique entre le saint
siège et l'état italien
depuis les accords de 1929 qui régissent
leur rapport le parquet de milan a
ouvert une information judiciaire contre
les trois principaux responsables de
l'institut des oeuvres de religion c'est
à dire l'organisme financier du vatican
le grand argentier du vatican
monseigneur paul marcinkus est le
premier visé le vatican a renvoyé la
communication du parquet sous prétexte
qu'elle n'avait pas emprunté la voie
diplomatique
alors que le vatican est un état
souverain mais l' enquête n'est pas
arrêtée pour autant l'enquète sur les
coffres du vatican et l'archevêque pas
comme les autres qui les supervisent
philippe harrouard voici monseigneur
marc chine qiu polmar chine qiu
archevêque
originaire de chicago est un personnage
hors du commun un mètre 86 85 kg
champion de karaté
passionné de golf amateur de whisky il a
su très vite se rendre indispensable
dans des tâches délicates
d'abord garde du corps du pape c'est lui
qui assure la protection du saint père
dans tous ses voyages
on se souvient qu'il a sauvé la vie de
paul 6 à manning neutralisant un
déséquilibre
mais monseigneur marc chine qiu est
aussi un personnage clé du vatican
puisque le pape en a fait le patron de
la banque du vatican l'ior et c'est là
que les choses se compliquent
londres 18 juin 1982 le banquier italien
roberto calvi est retrouvé mort
assassinat suicide l'enquète dira
suicide
roberto calvi c'est la banque ambrosiano
numéro 1 des banques privées italiennes
en pleine déconfiture
un trou de 1400 millions de dollars la
banque ambrosiano est liée à la banque
du vatican dirigé par monseigneur marc
chine cus elles font ensemble des
affaires à travers des filiales plus ou
moins fictives l'enquète sur la mort de
calvi révèle que l'ambrosia nos a
procédé à des opérations frauduleuses
notamment en amérique latine avec la
garantie de la banque du vatican
monseigneur martin kusch affirme qu'il
possède une lettre de calvi dégageant la
banque du vatican de ses responsabilités
dans ces opérations
mais les soupçons pèsent sur lui sur
monseigneur marc chine cus et sur luigi
ménoni un de ses collaborateurs
ce luigi meloni il est en ce moment en
prison pour avoir trempé dans un autre
scandale financier
la sphère sindona d'une honda banquiers
sicilien véreux et là encore le nom de
monseigneur marc chine cus est prononcée
alors affaires' donna affaires calvi
deux affaires très gênante quand même
pour un homme d'église au delà du ou des
scandales proprement dit le problème qui
pèsent sur la communauté financière
internationale est de savoir qui va
prendre en charge les dettes contractées
par la banque ambrosiano auprès de
quelques 200 banques étrangères
le conflit libanais est toujours pris ce
soir dans le double et au des armes et
de la diplomatie
les combats ont repris à beyrouth cet
après midi l'armée israélienne ayant
décidé de riposter très violemment aux
tirs palestiniens qui désignèrent avait
misé en brèche le cessez le feu obtenu
par le négociateur américain philip
habib notre envoyé spécial à
beyrouth-ouest patricia cost bruno cusin
le cameraman et le preneur de sons
jacques prévost ont été légers
armand blessé en fin de matinée par les
éclats d'un obus qui a tué net le jeune
combattant palestinien qu'ils étaient en
train de filmer le blocus israélien a
été maintenue aujourd'hui malgré une
résolution du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu demandant sa levée et voté hier
soir en marge du débat sur le projet de
résolution franco égyptien dont la
discussion a été suspendu le premier
ministre libanais menace de rompre les
négociations avec l'émissaire américain
philip habib sy le blocus n'est pas levé
la situation ce soir à beyrouth
philippe gassot c'est quelqu'un qui ont
été tirés ont paralysé les beyrouthins
c'était après deux journées le calme
accoutumé aux freelances et qui ont été
suivis quelques minutes par des raids de
l'aviation israélienne se sont
prolongées pendant près de deux heures
de bombardements intensifs concentrer
sur les camps palestiniens les faubourgs
de beyrouth en plein centre du montant
dû siffler les objets probablement tirée
par les vedettes israéliennes pour
pointer le centre-ville qui était visé
ce qui a déclenché une panique générale
les habitants du quartier couraient dans
tous les sens
affolé un moment une déclaration déjà
ancien de l'ol c'est qu'à n'est que les
collégiens s'engage à retirer leurs
troupes le verrou cet engagement a pris
un peu de poids car il est à présent
thuiller par un comité tuer la ligue
arabe qui étaient très optimistes fois
pour être moins aujourd'hui car il est
palestinien fond d'accord depuis
longtemps pour partir sont pas d'accord
sur les modalités
à washington le président reagan et le
ministre égyptien des affaires
étrangères qualifie pourtant le document
de la ligue arabe d étape positive
à jérusalem les réactions sont mitigées
quelle sera plus des quatre options que
le super guide a fixé aux palestiniens
pour régler la crise de beyrouth
premièrement israël s'en tient à
souhaitent actuellement jusqu'à présent
guy temps une solution politique qui
reste à déterminer d'une manière très
brève dans les jours qui viennent
deuxièmement la solution une fois fixés
sur plan politique les négociations
pourraient aboutir non pas de limite de
temps
jusqu'à présent troisièmement si cela ne
marche pas bien c'est l'assaut final
ou pire quatrièmement actions de
commandos ponctuelles
beyrouth jusqu'à la liquidation totale
de l'ol paie les choses vont donc un peu
vers l'optimisme de ce soir puisque
monsieur shamir le ministre italien des
affaires étrangères
en partant ce matin pour new york et
washington où il doit rencontrer ses
homologues américain a bien fait savoir
que finalement c'est vrai quelques
chances de progrès pourrait se réaliser
ces jours-ci dans les négociations
surveilleront par ailleurs monsieur
begin a lancé un nouvel avertissement à
la syrie qui a réinstallé dans la plaine
de la bekaa des batteries de missiles de
fabrication soviétique le kremlin
continue d'observer vis-à-vis du conflit
libanais un attentisme prudent dans un
message de félicitations au président
moubarak pour l'anniversaire de la
révolution égyptienne le président
brejnev ne dit mot de la situation au
proche orient
monsieur boris to man of vous aident à
moscou vous êtes le directeur adjoint
des relations extérieures de l'agent
stas depuis le début du conflit le
kremlin semble-t-il est très prudent
dans ses positions publiques hui à vis
de ce qui se passe au proche orient
alors pourquoi ne pas soutenir plus
manifestement la cause palestinienne et
les efforts que yasser arafat de sortir
de l'impasse de beyrouth
eh bien je ne suis pas totalement de
votre avis cet attentisme ou plutôt la
position de l'union soviétique que vous
taxez d'attentisme et plutôt prudente
dans la mesure où ce conflit peut
dégénérer en une
guerre régionale et partant peut-être
mondiale tout le monde le sait qu quand
quant aux réserves que vous attribuez
l'union soviétique dans le soutien de la
cause palestinienne je pense que c'est
un peu quand on dirais je ça ne peut pas
être qualifié comme cela étant donné que
le soutien total avaient été exprimées
aux palestiniens au peuple palestinien
et à yasser arafat dans le récent
message de camaraderie genève dans ses
réponses au journal la pravda
monsieur to man of la politique
internationale est également marquée
depuis plusieurs semaines par la
dégradation des relations entre l'europe
et les états unis alors comment
interprétons cette nouvelle situation à
moscou et en particulier la décision des
pays européens dans leur ensemble
d'aller jusqu'au bout des contrats qui
les lient à l'union soviétique et pour
la construction de ce fameux gazoduc et
bien vous voyez on s'attend à l'occident
je dirais enfin pas tout le monde
évidemment mais je sais qu'il ya certain
mass médias occidentaux qui s'attendent
à ce que les soviétiques manifeste
disons une espèce de mauvaises joua en
disant vouloir garder ils se bouffent le
nez les américains les européens etc
d'autre part il ya deux quinquis et le
présenter
disons le fait que l'europe occidentale
c'est un peu ruby fait pas ses mots le
mot contre l'embargo américain comme un
acte de courage civique comme quelque
chose de vraiment révolutionnaire comme
une mutinerie abordes tu navires de
l'otan ainsi de suite
eh bien je suis d'accord ni vin ni avec
l'un ni avec l'autre
justement ce qui concerne plus
spécifiquement les rapports entre paris
et moscou est ce que l'on considère à
moscou que la décision française de
passer outre l'embargo soviétique est un
pas vers un relatif réchaud ce
réchauffement des relations franco
soviétique
vous savez je ne peux pas dire non tout
simplement parce que je sais que l'union
soviétique veut avoir de bonnes des
meilleures relations avec la france que
nous considérons toujours comme un
facteur très important et très stable de
la paix de la sécurité européenne
d'autre part d'autre part vous voyez
vous je ne pense pas que la décision
nous voulons en france et c'est quelque
chose qu'on pourrait considérer comme
une fleur faite à moscou je répète
j'assiste sur le fait que c'est une
transaction commerciale dans laquelle
tout le monde trouve son compte
et alors vous voyez est flatté les
français parce que ils ont pensé à leur
poche
ça me paraît un peu exagéré voilà 7 à 9
merci beaucoup je vous en prie le
président a gan pense en tout cas à la
poche de ces agriculteurs il a autorisé
aujourd'hui la prolongation pour un an
de l'accord céréaliers qui permettent à
moscou d'acheter au moins 6 millions de
tonnes de céréales par an aux états unis
les élections parlementaires partielles
de novembre prochain aux états unis n'y
sont certainement pas étrangères en tout
cas pour justifier cette mesure en
contradiction flagrante avec l'embargo
exiger des européens concernant le
gazoduc la maison blanche souligne que
les ventes de céréales ont peu d'impact
sur les capacités militaires et indices
yelle soviétique le gouvernement
allemand a aussitôt critiqué la décision
américaine
l'industrie française de l'armement perd
une deuxième fois le marché belge après
le contrat du siècle conclut en 75 au
profit des avions américains
le gouvernement belge a opté nouvelle
fois pour le fc américains au lieu du
mirage français
pour rajeunir son aviation militaire
la loi sur le blocage des prix et des
revenus est conforme à la constitution
ainsi en a décidé aujourd'hui le conseil
constitutionnel la loi sera demain au
journal officiel la loi sur
l'audiovisuel a été publié aujourd'hui
le ministère du budget veut couper court
aux rumeurs qu'il attribue à une
campagne politique
pas d'augmentation de la pression
fiscale en 83 selon un communiqué du
ministère qui précise que le budget de
l'etat sera arrêté par le conseil des
ministres en septembre
d'autres rumeurs coupé net par le
ministre de l'urbanisme et du logement
monsieur cambo auteur d'un rapport sur
le développement des zones touristiques
qui préconisait selon certains une
taxation des résidences secondaires
monsieur cambo a été déchargé de sa
mission de réflexion 54 millions 257
milles c'est le chiffre de la population
française d'après les premiers résultats
de l'insee je vous le disais il ya
quelques jours ses résultats dans le
dépouillement est loin d'être terminée
permettent déjà de dresser région par
région une sorte de spectre graphie
démographique et économique du pays
jean claude renoult premiers points 40%
des français sont répartis dans quatre
régions et c'est bien sur l'île de
france avec paris qui est en tête du hit
parade avec 10 millions d'habitants
viennent ensuite rhône-alpes 5 millions
provence alpes côte d'azur près de 4
millions et nord pas de calais près de 4
millions également
deuxième point les régimes qui se
dépeuple deux seulement ont aujourd'hui
moins d'habitants dont 75 d'abord la
lorraine qui subit la plus grosse
hémorragie
elle a perdu treize mille trois cents
habitants soit -0 6%
la crise de la sidérurgie avec ses
milliers de suppressions d'emplois en
est certainement la cause principale
ensuite le limousin qui perd 0,8 pour
cent de sa population soit 6000
habitants pl c'est l'exode rural qui
compte il troisième point les régions
qui stagne il y en a 3 dont le nombre
d'habitants a augmenté mais de moins de
1%
l'auvergne la champagne ardennes et le
nord pas de calais
quatrième point les championnes de la
croissance qui ont gagné plus de 5%
d'habitants
on se rend compte que les français vont
vers le soleil et pas seulement pour les
vacances en tête le languedoc-roussillon
155 mille habitants de plus en sept ans
soit +8 7% deuxième provence alpes côte
d'azur 281 7000 habitants de plus +7 8%
3e les pays-de-loire 161 milles
habitants de plus + 5 8 %
quatrième le centre 115 mille habitants
de plus + 5,34 course il faudra attendre
que le traitement du recensement soit
plus avancée pour connaître qui sont ces
nouveaux habitants du soleil des
retraités ou bien des salariés du
tourisme ou d'autres secteurs vous saura
aussi alors qui sont les dix mille
habitants que la corse a gagné un
gardien de la paix a été tué aujourd'hui
à nantes au moment où il lui demandait
ses papiers il a été abattu par un homme
suspecté d'avoir agressé un passant
le meurtrier a réussi à s'enfuir un
portrait robot de deux des auteurs de
l'attentât qui a coûté la vie à une
semaine au numéro 2 de l'ol paie en
france vient d'être diffusée il s'agit
de l'homme qui a loué la voiture
utilisée par le commando et de l'un de
ses complices le monde de la
prostitution est sur le qui vive après
l'arrestation au début du mois à pigalle
d'henri botey de sa complice qui avait
mise à jour arrestation qui avait mis à
jour une vieille lucrative piliers le
ministre de l'intérieur poursuit
l'opération de nettoyage la police est
descendue aujourd'hui rue saint-denis à
paris pour faire évacuer studio et
sex-shop le monde nébuleux du
proxénétisme et ses ramifications
diverses sans sous le projecteur aux
milliards de centimes par an tous frais
payés
c'est ce que rapportait henry beauté et
à carmen vallée leur fleurissant réseau
de maisons de rendez-vous pour clients
de la haute société
mais ils n'étaient pas les seuls sur le
marché pas les seuls non plus à
bénéficier de protection très efficace
un rapport ultra confidentiel des
renseignements généraux datant de 1972
et concernant un autre proxénète de haut
vol surnommés tas qui permet de se faire
une idée d étrange relation qui ont
cours entre les gros bonnets du
proxénétisme
ceux de la police et ceux de la
politique jugez plutôt je cite le
rapport tas qui créent des safaris géant
train de plaisir via la belgique
location d'avions charter via
l'angleterre location de villas sur la
côte d'azur avec 300 participants et
poursuit des réjouissances en mer sur
des yo
la brigade mondaine et au parfum bien
sûr je cite toujours le rapport
ce service la brigade mondaine a suivi
le client mais eu égard aux protections
dont ils bénéficient et aux directives
le concernant venant des hautes sphères
de la direction générale de la police
il n'a pu envisager des poursuites au
pénal d'ailleurs fin janvier 1972
or des données en haut lieu de cesser
toutes les écoutes téléphoniques
elle était trop compromettantes pour
d'importantes personnalités de la
majorité de l'époque pour paris et la
proche banlieue 150 à 200 maisons de
rendez-vous sont ainsi protégés d'après
les auteurs du rapport chiffre
d'affaires total environ 6 milliards de
francs lourd de 1972 tarifs exigés par
certains policiers pour prix de leur
tolérance lui 1000 francs par mois pour
l'un 1000 francs par jour pour l'autre
c'est encore le rapport qu'ils ont
parfois ce sera un chèque de plusieurs
millions de centimes pour le bon
candidat aux élections présidentielles
proxénète et protecteur pour la plupart
sont nombreux du sac autres combines tas
qui a partie liée avec une grosse
société de publicité ses clients en
place et lui permettent d'arracher des
contrats juteux
l'un d'eux alors membre du gouvernement
et maire d'une grande ville de province
aurait même touché selon le rapport 10 %
des contrats ainsi conclu il faudra
attendre 1974 et certains règlements de
comptes à l'intérieur de l'ancienne
majorité pour que tu as qui perdent ces
protections de même que l' empire de
carmen valait heydari beauté la guerre
survécu au 10 mai 1981 depuis de tels
meurtres n'ont plus cours c'est promis 8
millions de francs c'est le montant des
dettes du club de football de bastia
hier soir ses dirigeants annonçait qu'il
mettait la clé sous la porte depuis ils
ont trouvé assez d'argent pour assurer
la participation de bastia au
championnat de france de première
division qui doit commencer le 10 août
prochain
olivier rey il y a quatre ans bastia
disputer la finale de la coupe d'europe
de l'uefa
l'année dernière encore l'équipe
bastiaise remportait pour la première
fois de son histoire la coupe de france
en battant saint-etienne
malgré ses très bonnes performances le
club corse accuse aujourd'hui un déficit
de 8 millions de francs c'est pour cette
raison qu'ils hier soir le comité
directeur annoncé qu'il mettait la clé
sous la porte
mais ce matin sous l'impulsion de
certains dirigeants bastia n'abandonnait
plus le professionnalisme les nouveaux
dirigeants ont en effet trouvé des 3
millions de francs nécessaires à la
survie du club corse
la mise à jour de limiter les dégâts
dans la première année et notre souci
c'est de prétendre la dette
va-t-il advenir du stade de furiani le
stade de furiani dans un état pas très
réjouissant nous comptons faire les
travaux de première urgence et notamment
ce qui me tient beaucoup à coeur
quelque chose je reçois pour vous
accueillir depuis correctement possible
parce que vous avez l'intention de faire
appel peut être aux corses pour aider le
club
c'est ce que je vais vous demander par
vos moyens radio télévisée appel à tous
les corses ne compte nous envisageons de
riz de souscription qui sera sous
contrôle judiciaire
bastia n'est pas sauvé pour autant grâce
à cette rentrée d'argent le club corse
va certes disputé le championnat de
france mais le problème reste entier
puisqu'il possède la plus faible moyenne
de spectateurs de la première division
peu de spectateurs donc peu de recettes
bastia va continuer à faire de la corde
raide
à moins que les pouvoirs publics ne
viennent à son secours
le tour de france à la voile le voyez le
havre a remporté hier la 13e étape les
sables d'olonne la rochelle au
classement général marseille est
toujours en tête
yves pélissier placée sous le signe des
temps hier soir loges de la rochelle
entre le bel espoir et le tour de france
à la voile
premier à jouir de cette vision
l'équipage de ville du havre vainqueur
de cette 15e étape entre les
sables-d'olonne et la rochelle
derrière gulli brest les sables
cherbourg marseille dunkerque
parmi eux les quatre premiers du
classement général tous les éléments
sont donc réunis pour que la bataille
entamée à dunkerque le 10 juillet
continue jusqu'à l'arrivée à menton
terme de la 23e étape le 15 août
il faut dire que cette course entre
voilier de 10 mètres tout strictement
identiques se joue uniquement sur les
qualités humaines basée à la fois sur
l'expérience et la volonté des possédés
par marc saignent de la tête du
classement général à la suite d'une
avarie dans l'étape précédente le havre
occupe une seconde place qu'il considère
comme provisoire dunkerque trois fois
vainqueur du tour est troisième alors
que brest hier cachant ce casse
respectivement quatrième et cinquième
ce sont là certainement les cinq
meilleurs éléments les intouchables de
cette longue épreuve
dans l'une des règles veut que les
équipiers se succèdent sur chaque bateau
afin d'en faire participer le maximum
des équipiers qui font parfois le dur
apprentissage de la vie en mer c'était
le cas ce matin les parisiens à la
recherche d'un nouveau skipper le leur
ayant regagné la capitale pour
incompatibilité d'humeur et la rochelle
direz vous
et bien c'est une excellente étape pour
le tour on aimerait aussi que cela soit
un excellent concurrents pourquoi pas
l'an prochain
l'été ce ne sont pas seulement les joies
de la mer c'est aussi traditionnellement
pour les agriculteurs l' angoisse de la
sécheresse plusieurs départements sont
dans une situation critique
le dossier jérôme baugnies la sécheresse
cette année est moins catastrophique que
celle de 1976 qui avait touché
l'ensemble du pays pourtant depuis le
coup de chaleur du début de l'été
la situation est particulièrement
préoccupante surtout dans cette région
du sud de la france c'est à dire il faut
le reconnaître des régions plus ou moins
habitués à une certaine sécheresse alors
que le nord de la france lui a été
épargné
dix départements sont particulièrement
touchés dont 4 déclarées sinistrées
le var la haute-loire le gère et la
lozère
ce sont surtout les petites communes
rurales s'alimentent en eau grâce à des
sources soit des nappes souterraines qui
ont des difficultés et c'est bien sur
l'agriculture qui est la plus touchée
notamment les éleveurs en lozère par
exemple les deux tiers du fourrage
récolté habituellement vont manquer
cette année
oh
à nous il ya une perte énorme au niveau
de l'alimentation animale qui va se
porter ce chiffre est jusqu'à 65% de la
forage de total qui est totalement
perdue pour les années 80 puisque chez
nous nous sommes un département
d'altitude et même l'y aider l'humidité
en arrière saison il y aura pas de pause
nous ne faisons que nous si on n'arrive
pas à acheminer des quantités
suffisantes de marchandises de toutes
façons les agriculteurs vont être
obligés de ce qu'on appelle deux décades
de décapitaliser c'est à dire vendre une
grosse partie du cheptel reproducteur ce
qui les condamne aura je pense 25 % des
exploitations à l'agonie dans la missive
autre conséquence de cette sécheresse
les incendies de forêt qui ont déjà
ravagé 20 mille hectares
surtout dans le var et en corse une
calamité qui préoccupe particulièrement
haroun tazieff
ainsi le vent demande ça peut être
vraiment catastrophique
nous avons déjà comme surface brûlée le
double de ce qui avait été volée à même
époque l'année dernière et le mit salle
en réalité ne s'est pas encore fait
sentir réellement
donc si le mistral s'élève et si la
sécheresse se poursuit
ça peut être catastrophique et quelles
sont les mesures que vous préconisez à
ce niveau là alors les mesures que je
préconise que j'avais préconisé
d'ailleurs il ya déjà pas de ça moi
c'est plutôt que de mettre toutes les
billes dans la lutte contre l' incendie
cédant mettre le maximum de ces vies
dans la prévention il vaut mieux
prévenir que guérir
or prévenir qu'est ce que c'est c'est
tout simplement débroussailler il faut
d'après moi le plus tôt possible
s'attaquer ou débroussaillement à
l'échelle qu'il le faut création
d'emplois lancement on relance d'un
certain type d'industrie national et en
même temps réduction drastique des
incendies à venir contre la sécheresse
en général de mesures vont être prises
aide financière aux communes surtout
pour installer des canalisations et
ouverture d'environ six barrages edf
dans des zones particulièrement touchées
alors un coup de baguette magique
elisabeth smsi vous fait pleuvoir vous
allez déplaire aux vacanciers oui c'est
difficile de plaire à tout le monde donc
il a fait très mauvais aujourd'hui enfin
partout avec de grosses averses d'orages
parfois très violentes et très violente
et bien sûr cela n'a pas facilité la
circulation principalement dans la
vallée du rhône mais demain je vous
rassure tout de suite et bien ça va
s'arranger du moins pour la grande
majorité d'entre nous alors un coup
d'oeil sur la photo prise ce matin par
le satellite et vous voyez cette grosse
tache là qui recouvre la france et bien
c'est une grosse perte une base
perturbation à l'origine de tous nos
soucis plus vieux d'aujourd'hui
plus à l'est vous le voyez là sur
l'atlantique et bien le temps est clair
c'est ce qui va nous arriver demain et
après demain
en revanche dimanche soir eh bien cette
nouvelle perturbation que vous voyez ici
risque de nous arriver
alors maintenant un peu plus en détail
sur la carte nous voyons ce qui nous
attend demain dans la moitié est ce de
demain matin encore un du mauvais temps
avec de la pluie mais ce mauvais temps
va se déplacer au cours de la journée
donc c'est ce que nous voyons ici sur la
carte à la mi journée seulement du
mauvais temps sur l'alsace le jura et
les alpes ailleurs un assez beau temps
avec tout de même davantage de nuages au
bord de la manche et même sur ces
régions des risques depuis depuis les
températures et bien il a fait un peu
plus chaud aujourd'hui on avait même
l'impression qu'il faisait nettement
plus chaud par moments puisque le temps
était lourd demain peu de changements
vous voyez 20 21 au bord de la manche
est et en bretagne et dans le sud est
bien des maxima à 27,28 jusqu'à 29
degrés en corse pour moi ce n'est tout
de même pas très très chaud pour la
saison et dimanche est bien une
il fera nettement plus beau partout avec
tout de même des risques de pluie le
soir au bord de l'atlantique
voilà demain nous serons le dernier jour
du mois de juillet le soleil toujours
prévoyons a décidé de mettre son réveil
à 624 il se couchera à 21h30 et ce sera
la fête des ignames à 22h55 jean claude
renaud vous présentera notre dernier
journal demain antenne de vidy avec
philippe labro je vous retrouverai
demain à 20 heures
bonne soirée sur antenne